>> Okay, so I've the cleaned up the screen
a little bit, Michael to, to make this a little
bit clearer. Now, let's look at this xi transpose
xj. And I'm now going to replace it with something.
So, I've just replaced it with a function,
which I'm going to call a kernel. Which takes
xi and xj as parameters, and will return
some number. And again, as we talked about
before, we think of the xi transpose xj,
as some notion of similarity, and so this
kernel function is our representation, still, of similarity.
Another way of thinking about that, by the way,
is that this is the mechanism by which we
inject domain knowledge into the support vector machine learning algorithm.
>> Just like we were injecting domain
knowledge when we were thinking about k-nearest neighbors.
>> Yes, everything has domain knowledge and
everything ultimately comes back to k-nearest neighbors.
I don't know why and I don't know how, but it always seems to.
>> So the k in k-nearest neighbors, and
the k in kernel really stand for knowledge.
>> Oh, wow, that's pretty good. We should write a paper with that title.
>> [LAUGH] So the room neatness here, the neatness here two fold. One is,
you can create these kernels and these kernels
have arbitrary relationships to one another. so, what
you're really doing is, projecting into some higher
dimensional space, where, in that higher dimensional space, your
points are in fact, linearly separable. But, the
second bit is, because you're using this kernel function
to represent your domain knowledge, you don't actually
have to do the computation of transforming the points
into this higher dimensional space. I mean, in fact if you think about it, with
the last kernel that we used, computationally,
there was actually no more work to be
done. Before we were doing x transpose y, and now we're still doing x transpose
y, except we're then squaring it. So
that's just a constant bit more work. Right?
>> So is, and that is a kernel and another kernel is X transpose Y?
>> Yes, that's something I would call a kernel.
>> And the other kernel we talked about was just X transpose Y by itself.
That's, that's a kernel too, isn't it?
>> Oh no, no. That's right. That's right.
That's absolutely right. So, that's a different kernel,
you're absolutely right. Just X transpose Y. Is
another kernel. Actually we can write a general
form of both of these. And as a
very typical kernel, it's the polynomial kernel where
you have x transpose y plus some constant,
let's call it c, raised to some power p.
And as you can see, both of those earlier
kernels are, in fact, just a special case of this.
>> Hm, and I would, yeah, okay, good.
>> And that should look familiar.
>> It reminds me of the regression lecture.
>> Exactly, where we were doing
polynomial regression. So now, rather than doing
polynomial regression the way we were thinking
about it before, we use a polynomial
kernel and that will allow us
to represent polynomial functions. And there're lots
of other kernels you can come up with, Michael. So. Here's just a couple.
I will just sort of leave em. Leave em up to
you, to think about. And there's, there's tons of them. So,
here's one that I, I happen to like. So, that's a
a sort of, radial basis kernel. Does that look familiar to you?
>> Well, to me, make sure I understand
that it's doing the right thing. So if x
and y are really close to each other, then
it's like, e to the minus zero over something
which is like e to the zero, which is like
one. So there's similarities like one if they're on top
of each other. If they're very far apart, then it's
like their distance is something very big divided by something
e to the minus something very big is very close
to zero. So it does have that kind of property
kind of like the sigmoid where it, it transitions between zero
and one but it's not exactly the same shape as that.
>> Right in fact it's symmetric, that the square
of the of the distance between you in making an
actual distance, makes it always a positive value there. Or at
least a non-negative value there. And so it becomes symmetric,
so it looks a lot more like a, like a gaussian
with some kind of width which is represented by sigma.
And there are tons and tons of these. Actually if you
wanted to get something that looked like a sigmoid, here's
one. Where alpha's different from the other alphas, but I couldn't
think of a different Greek letter. And this function gives you
something that looks a lot more like a sigmoid. And there're
tons and tons of these you can come up with. And
there's lots of, been a lot of research over the years
on what makes a good kernel function. The most important thing
here, I think, is that it really captures your, your domain
knowledge. It really captures your notion of similarity. You might notice,
Michael, that since it's just an arbitrary function that returns a number,
it means that X and Y or the, the different data points you have, don't have
to actually be points in a numerical space.
They could be discrete variables. They could describe whether
you're male or female. As long as you
have some notion of similarity to play around
with, that you can define, that returns a
number, then it doesn't matter. It will always work.
>> So can you do things like, I don't know, strings or graphs or images?
>> Absolutely. You could think about two strings. How are
two strings similar? Maybe they're, they're similar if their edit
distance is small. The number of transformations that you have
to give in order to transform one string to another. If
there are few of those, then they're very similar. If
there are a lot of those then they're very dissimilar.
You could talk about words like cat and lion, and
decide those are more similar than cat and mosquito, for example.
>> because
they, because of the ears?
>> Yeah. Mainly because of the ears.
>> All right. But then I, then I think I understand.
>> Okay. Good. So you might be
curious, Michael, whether there are any bad kernel
functions. There is actually an answer to that.
While it's not clear whether there are any
bad kernel functions, it is the case that in order for all the math to
go through, there is a specific technical requirement
of a kernel function. It has a name.
And it's the Mercer Condition. Have you ever heard of the Mercer Condition?
>> I've heard the word. I actually used
to live near Mercer County in New Jersey.
>> You did?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh. So then I guess it's the condition of living near
where Michael used to live. Now, so the Mercer condition is a very
technical thing we'll talk about this again, a little bit in the
homework assignment. But for your intuition
in the meantime, it basically means it
acts like a distance, or it acts like a
similarity. It's not an arbitrary thing that doesn't relate the
various points together. Being positive is something definite in
in this context means it's a well behaved distance function.
>> Gotcha.